(audience cheering)
(drum roll)
- All right.
So they given me extra.
'cause we love Charles
actually extra. Yeah.
I didn't know this about
you, but you start,
and I feel like I've known you for a bit,
but like you started
on Broadway. I didn't.
- I started on Broadway.
I didn't finish it.
- I know, but I didn't know that.
- Well. Yeah. Well, I mean, I love
that you, New York suits you.
- I love New York.
- Really well. I can tell that Kelly.
It comes right through the screen.
- Yeah.
- And it suited me for a quick minute.
I was in Los Angeles and auditioned
for the show called Smokey Joe's Cafe.
It was a review of the songs of Lieber
and Stoller's. So great.
- I perform that pop choir in high school.
- You did?
- Yep.
- Years before that I
auditioned for the Broadway show
and I just had a really great audition.
For years before that, I
would get a vocal audition
for a Broadway show
and they'd go, all right,
they wanna see a callback.
And I go, for what?
And they say, oh, they,
it's a dance audition.
I go, well I don't dance,
so I probably shouldn't go do that.
- Yeah. Just show up
and lie and say you can.
- No, That's what they said.
They just wanna see if you can move.
And apparently I can't move.
But anyway, this one audition,
I just was free and loose.
I did a couple Elvis songs. Hound dog.
Leiber and Stoller wrote
Hound Dog and Jailhouse Rock.
- Yeah.
- And so I think I bamboozled them.
And then I went here and Broadway
and we were rehearsing
in the studios downtown.
And I looked around and I
was surrounded by people
that were just legit Broadway talent.
My leading lady was DeLee
Lively and she was unbelievable.
Such a great dancer, singer.
And then I think it was
about three weeks in,
the director finally showed
up to see where we were.
And I could just see on
his face him watching me,
you know that thing we have
like imposter syndrome?
And you're like, I don't belong here
and everybody's gonna figure that out.
- Yeah. I have that all the time.
- Well, they figured it out.
I'll tell you. He looked
at me and he said in
front of everybody, he
stopped the whole thing.
He goes, let me ask you
a question. Do you dance?
And I said, well Jerry,
that falls under things you
should have asked at the audition.
And I said, I'm doing my best.
I will get it by Showtime.
I promise you that.
About a week later he gave
me a very nice phone call
and he said, we really
appreciate your hard work,
but we're gonna have to.
- Oh.
- So they recast the role.
- Oh, man.
- And the first thing I found
out was that I had a contract.
So I got paid for a year
for not being in that show.
- That's amazing.
- That's like the one time
you're thankful for contracts.
- It was unbelievable.
I met six months in, I go to my mailbox,
I'm like, honey, I got a raise.
I got a bump at six months.
So, and another thing
I found out is if I had done that show,
I would not have been available to get on
Whose Line Is it Anyway?
- Oh, love.
- Which changed my life being on
that show for a number of years.
And then a final couple, two things.
Years later, six or eight years later,
we're walking some fair in in
L.A. and we see DeLee Lively
and her husband, who was the
guy they replaced me with.
- Oh.
- All these things had to happen.
- They had three kids,
they had one in her arm,
one in the stroller, one
walking, and they were amazing.
And we talked and it was really even I go,
I think it's very important
that you guys understand
and know and remember that
you have all this bliss.
You have this paradise
because Charles Esten can't dance.
(guests laughing)
- You are welcome.